bonsoir clair un minot merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france tout
d'abord dans quelles conditions se sont
déroulées ces évacuations du grand camp
du camp pardon de grande synthe
oui monsieur le préfet du nord avait
extrêmement fier parce que tout s'est
déroulé dans le calme effectivement ça
s'est déroulé dans le calme c'est à dire
que ils ont fait monter les gens dans
les autobus sans coups de matraque e100
mitraillette dans le dos simplement les
gens savaient très bien qu'ils avaient
le choix entre monter dans les bus ou
monter dans un autre bus direction la
police dans ces cas là les gens montrent
très très beau métier dans l'autobus
qu'on leur propose pour une mise à
l'abri sachant que cette mise à l'abri
google n'est absolument pas une solution
parce que une mise à l'abri
il ne permet pas de demande d'asile
n'est pas une mise à l'abri les gens qui
sont chez nous sont à 95% soit dégoûté
c'est à dire qu'ils ont été refusées on
leur a refusé le droit d'asile
les pays scandinaves et à la fois ou en
alternative et josé fameuse empreinte
dublin à dire qu'on a pris leur
empreinte quand ils sont en train de
voir dans un autre pays que la france
donc et le board qui s'appelle au tac et
qui repère à dans quel pays on a les
empreintes digitales et c'est là on est
renvoyé demander l'asile faire venir des
gens dans un centre d'accueil sans lever
ses empreintes du bla
ça ne sert absolument à rien pour
ça veut dire que quand le ministre de
l'intérieur parle de mise à l'abri c'est
un terme que vous réfutez vous en tant
qu'association tout à fait c'est un
terme que nous réfutons réfutons parce
que de toutes façons ces gens là on en a
qui sont partis dans la région dans ma
vie sont partis loin à 17 heures j'ai
noté leur ou d'un appel du hasch héros
il dit que des gens sont encore dans un
autre cas après 17 heures partis ce
matin ils ne savent pas au niveau et
l'autocar roule et donc dirigeants
pendant même très loin et ne savent pas
où ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils vont
devenir ça ne ment pas ils sont
acheminés
à donc est ce qu'on sait où ils sont
acheminés donc justement
les producteurs de l'autocar j'espère
que c'est mais les gens qui montent dans
l'autocar et ceux qui les voient partir
de le simple et ça c'est toujours comme
ça quand on a des évacuations où qu'elle
soit obligatoire ou choisie se passe
toujours sans que les gens qui montent
dans le toquin sèche ou alors vous êtes
séduit la famille on sait aussi et c'est
important de souligner que quoi qu'il
arrive ces migrants ne sont pas
satisfait mon avis puisque leur cible
finale étant quand même le royaume uni
est pas forcément une demande d'asile en
france
alors leur but là leur but et le royaume
uni parmi et ses jambes y en a une
proportion qui certainement souhaite le
royaume uni à ce qu'ils y ont de la
famille parce que il parle parfaitement
l'anglais les mêmes des gens qui parlent
anglais même des gens qui ont une
famille souvent si à leur offrait une
situation en france avec des papiers et
le droit de travailler ensemble vous
croyez qu'on a envie de se mettre sur un
canot pneumatique va traverser la manche
comme ça en sachant qu on risque sa vie
dans sa chambre mais ses enfants sur
l'eau et qu'ils risquent leur vie vous
croyez qu'on leur fait de gaieté de
coeur parce qu'on a envie d'aller s'il
avait une autre solution s'ils étaient
accueillis en france
trois quarts de ces gens je suis
persuadé que s'il avait des papiers
après ils pourraient aller voir leur
famille en angleterre s'il avait des
papiers et l'autorisation de travailler
pourrait faire la réussite se trouvait
une situation en france
alors que l'angleterre en c'est en tout
cas la france est pointée du doigt pour
son traitement des migrants vaut aussi
en tant qu'association vous avez été
témoin de traitement inhumain de ces
personnes dans le nord de la france
avait complètement oublié demain c'est
pas des gens qui sont battus c'est pas
des gens qui sont matraqués qui
reçoivent rarement 1 reçoivent de gaz
lacrymogènes par contre ils sont dans
des camps
clairement on va leur prendre toutes
leurs affaires on rate complètement le
camp n'ont plus rien les associations
n'ont plus de tentes et de bâches à
distribuer se demande la ce soir à
grande synthe ce qu'on va trouver pour
mettre à l'abri ceux qui ne sont pas
parties et il n'y a pas à grande synthe
qui a pas de toilettes rien absolument
pas une cabine de toilette ya pas de
douche il ya des deux gymnases de
dunkerque deux fois dans
une possibilité à des associations de
d'encadrer les gens pour qu'ils prennent
une douche mais là ils sont devenus
tellement nombreux que les associatifs
qui peuvent le faire non plus on peut
plus il ya trop de monde qui vient vous
prendre une douche et on y arrive on se
souvient que c'est vraiment qu'il s'agit
on se souvient qu'en 2017 et autorités
ne souhaitait pas à la construction de
d'accueil notamment de nos gymnastes
parce qu'il craignait un appel d'air
notamment gérard collomb est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'était un bon choix ce
que cela a changé quelque chose
rien du tout le l'appel d'air c'est pas
pas les conditions d'accueil quand on
voit les gens qui arrivent actuellement
le nombre de gens qui arrivent alors
qu'il fait mauvais effet alors qu'il
pleut alors que regarder vous avez
l'image est alors qu'on leur enlève leur
tante que ils partent avec un tout petit
paquet d'agen
et quelles sont celles qui vont revenir
et qui n'auront plus rien c'est pas
l'accueil pour l'europe qui fait un
appel d'air c'est l'angleterre c'est ce
set c'est ce sentiment qui n'ont que ça
comme solution comme ailleurs comme
angleterre ils ne peuvent pas l'aider
tout à l'heure ils sont dégoûtés ils ont
les empreintes dublin et voit plus
d'autre solution mais on leur offre une
autre solution et et resteront ils
seront contents de rester et pour ça et
à ce moment là évidemment des centres
d'accueil qui soit digne la ccl et
priant le manque de dignité le manque
d'humanité avec lequel on reçoit ces
gens merci beaucoup plaire mais nos
secrétaire général de l'association
salam un d'avoir témoigné en direct sur
rt france ce soir dément